as freezing cold weather takes over much
of the united states some
snarky conservatives are claiming
that they wish we had some global
warming this is extremely ignorant
though
very very ignorant to tie a weather
event
to the climate because the democrats
have told us time and time again
weather is not climate unless of course
those weather events are convenient for
the democrats climate arguments in which
case
every single weather event is proof of
global warming but even more broadly
okay beyond one winter storm here
or one hurricane there what democrats
have told us
if they've told us once they've told us
a thousand times
any weather event whatsoever whether
it's hot whether it's cold whether it's
dry whether it's wet
whether it's perfectly temperate any
weather event at all
is proof of global warming okay and
that's just the science
we're going to follow the science all
the way down on a whole host of topics
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like goodness gracious guys can't
you read a blog
can't you can't you read some blue
checkmark leftists on twitter
to know that the science is whatever the
left-wingers say
how dare you make jokes about global
warming as i broadcast here from my
house uh third day in a row
another snow day here in beautiful
nashville my favorite comment from
yesterday
from larry who says it's so cold here in
texas
i went outside and saw a politician's
hands in his own pockets wow that really
is shocking
my goodness that must be the the coldest
weather we've seen in quite
a while but but don't worry don't worry
because while these politicians
are trying to warm up their hands in
their own pockets at the same time i
don't know how they're capable of this
they are still reaching into yours and
they're spending your money on some
pretty bad stuff which we will get to
in just a moment you know i've been
snowed in here with my friends for a few
days
and when i'm hanging out with my friends
sometimes we have a couple coca-colas
a couple adult beverages and a great way
to make your next morning feel a little
bit better
liquid iv you know good people use
liquid iv
to rehydrate after sports after going on
a run
maybe just you know to get through all
of this incredibly warm weather that
we're experiencing
or your normal day-to-day hydration but
for me i got to tell you
i sometimes hang out with the guys you
know
as i've been snowed in here hanging out
with my friends having a couple
coca-colas a few adult beverages
liquid iv great way to have a good next
morning
one serving of liquid iv provides the
same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
contains five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana it's made
with clean ingredients non-gmo vegan
and free of gluten dairy and soy so
you're good i know you're always afraid
gosh i don't know what's going on in
this packet
totally clean stuff really really
effective i
really like liquid iv it's effective
because of cellular transport technology
do i understand how that works not
really but what i do know is it has been
proven effective
to hydrate you a lot better than just
water alone grab your strawberry liquid
iv
or other great flavors in bulk
nationwide at costco or
you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code michael mich
aela checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code michael at liquidive.com
get better hydration today at liquid
iv.com promo code
michael i have long argued that the word
science should be banned from political
discourse
i know there are some conservatives and
this is
in a an insightful point of view but i
don't think it goes far enough
some conservatives observe that
left-wingers
abuse the word science they don't really
listen to the science you know they
manipulate science for their own ends
conservatives really do pay attention to
the science on things like
abortion or on things like biological
sex or
whatever but even beyond that i think
there's a deeper level we have to get to
which is that while all sorts of
information about the natural world can
inform our political points of view
science should not dictate politics
why because science as in the way we use
the term today tells us about our
natural world
but politics tells us how we want
to live how we want to get along
together it doesn't just take on
you know discrete problems uh from the
the finite world but it deals with
eternal questions
how shall we implement justice
what is equality how do we make sense of
our liberty
what is our society for there aren't
narrow
scientific answers to those questions
those are questions that require
philosophy they require
a culture and tradition they require
theology
because ultimately all human conflict
comes down to religious
questions what are we what are we here
for where are we going
using the word science in a political
debate is just a trick
to cut off the debate nobody uses it in
good faith
so let's get rid of it okay
democrats have been using science
obviously with the global warming
hysteria
but most recently with the coronavirus
lockdowns and then
when the scientific bodies say for
instance
that it's perfectly fine to open up
schools there's no evidence that the
virus is being
particularly transmitted in schools or
to teachers or anything like that what
do the democrats do they abandon it
and they do the bidding of the teacher
unions ron desantis is receiving a lot
of pressure right now
to reopen the state of florida you've
got a republican governor he's done a
great job on coronavirus
he's receiving a lot of pressure rather
to keep florida closed
to re-close florida even after he had
opened it and specifically
to keep the schools closed ron desantis
says absolutely not
he's not going to pay any attention to
those teachers unions
we followed the data when we work to get
the kids get the parents the option to
send the kids back
because we had looked at what happened
in europe places like sweden and all
these other places
and it does not require another hundred
billion dollars
the school reopening plan that makes the
most sense if you want to open schools
open them open the door let them come in
and let them learn and the only reason
that that is not happening across this
country like it is in florida like it is
in a handful of other states
it's one reason and one reason only
because the democratic party puts the
interests of
education unions and special interests
ahead of the well-being of our children
and of our families
he's absolutely right there's no
question about it
he is invoking science i think a lot of
practicing politicians have to do this
because this is the language that
everybody speaks
and so therefore you want to appeal to
that language i i don't fault him for it
but in the long term i think we need to
get away from that and say wait a second
i don't care what people in lab coats
tell me
there is not an inevitable course of
politics politics involves debating
moral and ethical questions
and actually asserting a little sway
over how we want to run our lives that's
what self-government is
in america the founding fathers didn't
give us government by lab coats that's
not the purpose of the constitution it
was to give a self-government we have
the right to say
well i'm i understand there's x amount
of risk if we reopen the schools we
might get the virus but i'm willing to
take that risk
because i think that education is
important so on and so forth desantis
obviously running for president in 2024
right i think it's
pretty clear at this point he'd be crazy
not to he's put himself in a very good
position
a lot of people are calling for him to
run in 2024. you can tell
that he's he's a really adept politician
probably a little more politically
sophisticated or politically polished
than say donald trump because desantis
doesn't use this word
teacher union so usually we're
considered as rail against the teacher
unions
desantis doesn't did you hear what he
said he said the education
unions and the special interests
now what's a special interest everybody
has special interests don't we but
the term special interests that sounds
really bad and really dark
just like teacher unions a lot of people
like their teachers
but education union i don't know i don't
have any particular
draw to an education union it's a
it's a way to take away your affinity
for that particular group i have long
compared desantis
to chris christie and some people think
i'm being insulting when i say that i'm
not comparing him to chris christie
in 2016 or 2020. i'm comparing him to
chris christie in 2012
where at the time you had this very
serious
very popular very effective governor who
was a state politician
for basically his whole career and was
doing a good job and he talked tough and
he knew how to
how to work different groups christie in
particular knew how to
uh sort of go after certain public
sector unions
that previously had had a lot of sway in
his state actually specifically going
after the teacher union
i think desantis is doing a good job at
that too puts him in a good position
he's obviously right on the question of
science and more importantly in the
question of politics
how is the white house handling covid
science you might want to know
well since inauguration day
about 87 000 people have died in the
united states
from coronavirus hard to get exact
numbers because the reporting is a
little spotty but
call it about 87 000 which means
by the logic of joe biden by the logic
of the democratic campaign in 2020
joe biden killed 87 000 people
can you believe that gosh we got to
impeach this guy
we got to take power away from him
before he kills more people
because we were told joe biden actually
told us this himself
donald trump was responsible for every
single coronavirus death that occurred
while he was president
now reasonable people might have said
look epidemics happen and
it's not the president's fault that an
epidemic happens and actually trump did
a very good job right he
everyone told him there's no way you
could get the vaccine in time
there's no way you could get it within a
year right all the experts
all the media all the democrats said you
couldn't get that vaccine and then what
happens he gets a vaccine
conveniently a day or two after the
election it was clearly ready to go
right right within the year actually by
the fall so he did a good job but still
biden says all the debts are his fault
so okay
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander joe biden is now personally
responsible
for 87 000 people dying from coronavirus
what are they doing moving forward how
is this vaccine that trump got us how is
this vaccine
rolling out well kamala harris says
uh maybe you should lower expectations i
mean the challenge
mike is you know what i explained to the
mayors
um there was no stockpile
right it's in many ways
no stockpile of of vaccines
right so we're looking at this there was
no national
strategy or plan for vaccinations we
were leaving it to the states and local
leaders to try and figure it out and so
in many ways we are com we're starting
from scratch
on something that's been raging for
almost an entire year there was no
stockpile we were told by you guys and
by the entire liberal establishment that
it was ridiculous to expect that there
would be a vaccine
in 2020 that there would be a vaccine
even by now
trump managed to achieve that because of
his leadership on the virus
and now you're complaining that what he
didn't leave enough
extras how many millions of people have
been vaccinated already how many
millions of vaccines have gone out
in the places where the vaccine rolled
out got bungled where was it
it was democratic states it was new york
it was andy cuomo
who handled coronavirus worse than
anybody in this country
you actually because of cuomo's policies
on on the vaccine
you had people throwing out vaccines
vaccines being wasted
because he had a special tier system of
who
gets to receive it constantly
passing the buck and these are the these
are the expert geniuses
that we're told we have to follow by the
way fauci said
that we're not starting from scratch on
vaccine distribution
he came he actually contradicted vp
kamala harris
axios uh left leaning outlet posted this
tweet they then deleted it because
the news didn't look too good for the
white house didn't look too good
for kamala harris it shows you that the
state of journalism is
about the same as the state of uh
science and politics in this country
not so great you know
one scientific and technological
breakthrough that i really like
ring because you can see who is outside
of your door before you open that door
there are a lot of people showing up to
our doors these days
you may have heard a doorbell or two go
off even during
this broadcast today people showing up
because they want to bring over baby
clothes they want to bring over food
they want to come visit
the little baby like my in-laws well
depending on who it is at the door
maybe i'm going to answer maybe i'm
going to stay perfectly still and
pretend
that no one's home you can do that with
ring a ring
allows you to see and speak with whoever
is at the door before you
open the door a super cool very
futuristic sort of technology it's why i
give it off
i give it away as a housewarming gift to
my friends another reason i give it as a
housewarming gift
it's not particularly expensive great
way to get peace of mind you can check
in on who's at your door whether you're
at home whether you're in the office
maybe you're on a beach somewhere
on the other side of the world right now
you can get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit
at ring.com knowles know les comes with
rings video doorbell 3
and chime pro the perfect way to upgrade
your front door and start your ring
experience
and by the way you can grow your ring
experience from there they have a ton of
other great products
go to ring dot com slash knowles
w l e s that is ring.com
knowles axios deletes a tweet
in which dr fauci the exalted one peace
be upon him
contradicts vp kamala harris i know this
would be impossible
these are the two most wonderful people
in the country how on earth
how could they possibly be disagreeing
so the left didn't like that axios was
reporting on this so they delete the
tweet
frankly axios is the gold standard of
journalism today compared to
places like the new york times or the
washington post the new york times
you'll recall
when covering the capitol hill riot they
covered this very sad the death of
officer brian siknik and they reported
that a trump supporter bashed officer
sicknick in the head
with a fire extinguisher right this was
a
key piece of evidence in the narrative
that was building up about the capital
riot
leading into the impeachment trial of
donald trump
the second impeachment trial of donald
trump i i know that now i have to
specify so the new york times even
though we've known
that the the fire extinguisher story was
complete bunk it wasn't true
no evidence that officer sicknick got
hit in the head with an extinguisher
they would not retract the story we've
now known this for a long time they
would not retract the story
until conveniently right after the
impeachment trial of trump
drats they didn't get him there was
there was no way they were going to
convict
unfortunately trump gets to live to see
another political day
so the new york times finally admits the
story was bogus they say quote update
new information has emerged regarding
the death of the capital police officer
brian sicknick that questions the
initial cause
of his death provided by officials close
to the capitol police
okay but they actually had to rewrite
the the initial article because
what we were told was law enforcement
officials initially
said mr sicknick was struck with a fire
extinguisher
but weeks later police sources and
investigators were at odds
over whether he was hit and medical
experts say he didn't die of blunt force
trauma so therefore you know
this is one law enforcement official so
what is it
is it official is it law enforcement
officials or officials
close to the capitol police
this would seem to matter you know it
seems like minor details but when you're
talking about
the death of this officer during this
riot that is being used as
the single piece of evidence this riot
in the impeachment of
a former president that in itself
unprecedented don't you think you should
be specific on the details
but no it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter don't you think when you
when you're talking about things i mean
i guess kind of ties in more broadly to
what we're talking about today
global warming science the apocalypse
coming upon us right we've got 12 years
of the world is going to end the left
tells us
some leftists tell us it's going to end
even sooner unless we do exactly what
they say
and give them the power but they're
never really specific is the world going
to end because
it's going to get a lot colder and we're
going to have a new ice age like they
told us in the 70s
and that's why we have to give them all
this new power or is the world going to
end
because the earth is warming and it's
going to be really really hot
and that's why we have to give them all
the same powers or is the world maybe
not not exactly warming maybe there's
sort of a pause going on in the warming
and actually you know the polar bears
are doing just fine and actually the
arctic ice is doing
basically just fine so it's remaining
more or less
the same as it ever was but that
that as well as evidence that the world
is going to end we have to give them all
this new power don't you think the
details matter
when you're talking about fundamentally
reordering society constitutional
government
uh property rights all all these very
important facets of our society
you would think that sort of thing would
matter but but who would call them out
on it
the scientific experts are in bed with
the politicians
right even just the field of public
health itself public
political health scientific dr fauci a
scientist who's worked for
the government for 40 years how many
presidents has fauci worked for at this
point
and the media of course part of the
liberal establishment too and totally in
bed with the
with the democrats there was a very
important headline in newsweek i don't
know if you caught it that you know
because i
i try to read all the most important
news a newsweek is reporting quote joe
biden
playing as luigi wins in mario kart race
against
granddaughter at camp david
man i was worried there for a second i
was worried the president might lose or
he might he might play as bowser or
something he might play as
peach i don't know i haven't played
mario in quite a while this is the
article seriously i'm not making this
it's not the babylon be
article says how did joe biden relax
during his first president-day weekend
as president by playing mario kart with
his family during his weekend retreat at
camp david biden and his granddaughter
naomi that's one of the grandchildren
that he's willing to acknowledge
there are other grandchildren of course
that joe biden refuses to acknowledge
in a very cruel and callous way still
refuses to acknowledge them all these
all these months and years later but
naomi she's one of the nice
grandchildren that he will acknowledge
uh played the racing video game and he
won naomi shared a video to instagram
that showed biden competing against her
on the arcade gpdx machines complete
with chairs and steering wheels
biden sat on the right as luigi and
naomi's princess peach on the left okay
i can't i can't read this anymore
imagine imagine what the media would
have written about trump
idiot trump who is lazy and
incompetent at his job wastes time
playing video games
with nazi grandchildren right it's like
i think very that'd be like a soft
headline
in the trump administration but this is
just the only reason i bring it up it's
kind of funny
is is to show you there will not be
journalism
the closest thing you're going to get to
any reporting is
from the right you're going to get some
conservative outlets where we're still
permitted i guess to broadcast every now
and again
but of course we're siloed and no matter
how robust the conservative ecosystem is
daily wire does pretty well
but daily wire is one source right
compared to
nbc abc cbs cnn so so you
you could read a headline that says
daily wire does well on facebook you
know we
we're a big publisher on facebook where
we do you know bench bureau show
one of the top podcasts in the world
we're catching up we're getting close
but still you know
the michael knowles show big show andrew
clavin show what you know this
matt wall show these are bigger shows
that's one outlet
compared to every newspaper basically
every tv network basically increasingly
including the so-called right-wing ones
every
major radio outlet not am talk radio
that's still held by conservatives but
the rest of
much of the digital space all the tech
platforms which are increasingly
people's sources of news
it's all dominated by the left and
you're not going to get any reporting
here's what you're going to get from cnn
another bit of breaking news i don't
this is shocking stuff obviously of
great national import so if you're
driving right now please pull over your
car
headline from cnn inside the new
president's routine
oval office fires and early bedtimes
joe biden goes to bed early not exactly
a man bites dog story
it's that's actually what they're
reporting they say quote
unlike his most recent predecessors
night owls who spent the dark hours
reading briefing materials
president obama or watching television
president trump can you believe that
even
you know donald trump even his worst
critics should be able to admit that
guy's a workaholic he's working all the
time he's
infamous for doing so but they say no
you know obama's reading and doing
important work at night
and uh donald trump you know he's just
up watching tv
like some idiot at night by the way what
was
bill clinton doing in those early
morning hours cnn seems to have left
that out neither here nor there we'll
talk about it another time
but what cnn wants to report is unlike
trump and obama who stayed up late
biden is more of an early to bed type
gee you don't say and this is also
important quote he has expressed a
preference for a fire built in the oval
office fireplace
and sometimes adds a log himself to keep
it going
his dogs two german shepherds called
major and champ sometimes
join him this is all just
framing right i mean obviously none of
this matters but all this to say
we like joe biden right if donald trump
had gone to bed early what was it
trump in over his head lazy
stupid can't keep up with the job
trump he likes fires yeah he likes fire
he's an arsonist is what he is
right but joe biden does it oh goodness
how sweet you just picture a grandfather
going to bed early
making a nice nice fire what they're
actually doing is just admitting that
trump was right to call biden's sleepy
joe he is sleepy joey gets very sleepy
goes to bed early
meanwhile meanwhile while sleepy uncle
joe
sits by the fire in the oval office
warming his hands because it's so chilly
out with all that global warming
the cognizant people in his
administration are enacting
radical policies we were told that joe
biden
is going to govern like a moderate
you know he's going to resist the
extremes of the party no don't worry
in the last days of the campaign and
then in the
the runoff in georgia when the senate
control was being decided
they sent moderates like joe manchin on
tv
don't worry about this idea there's
going to be radical policy under biden
and then what happens well cnn crafts
this idea that biden is he's this nice
warm moderate guy sitting by the fire
the
actual people who are running the show
the bureaucrats the staffers in his
administration
are pushing radical radical policies
i don't want to end up like joe all
tired and sleepy and unable to keep my
eyes open
which is why by the way i am starting to
exercise i've never been much of one for
exercising
but then i got total gym and boy oh boy
do i love total gym i really do
i love working out at home i don't love
working out that has never been
something that i've been interested in
but i would always
hate it where the few times i would work
out i'd go i'd get changed i drive 15 20
minutes to the gym then i get out then i
maybe you got to get ready there then
you do a little workout then you got to
you got to shower you got to get changed
again you got to leave
so you've taken an hour and a half of
your life how much did you work out like
three or four minutes
the thing i love is total gym fit
because total gym
fit allows me to work out in my own home
i just walk right upstairs
it is incredibly effective these guys
have been making fitness equipment for
over
45 years they have an a plus better
business bureau
rating i'm sure you remember the
commercials with chuck norris and
christy brinkley i'm going to become
chuck norris
by beach season i'm going to be chuck
norris i'm telling you that right now
it's a really serious workout i'm not
just saying that because i'm not
particularly in shape
you can start out kind of slow and easy
but you can work your way all the way up
i because i'm sort of prideful i started
out on the really heavy one and
you know i'm definitely feeling it the
next day which is what you want no pain
no gain
right now total gym is offering a 30-day
in-home trial
on the total gym fit that's the one that
i have for just one
dollar seriously just one dollar what do
you have to lose
no matter which total gym you try my
listeners can get an additional 20
off whatever discount they're currently
running so it's not you know maybe
there's uh
sort of a discounted price on the
website you get another 20 off just head
to totalgymdirect.com
knowles to get this special offer then
you too can look
like me looking like chuck norris you
got to go to that url
totalgymdirect.com and all's get an
additional 20 off
i'm going to be so fit by beach season
that i'm going to look like some kind of
mma fighter i'm going to look like
a movie star because i'm going to have
to because i'm now
colleagues with an mma fighter movie
star named gina carano
disney plus disney the whole walt disney
company they tried to cancel her
because she made perfectly ordinary
comments that were in no way
objectionable really they canceled her
because she's a conservative
well that's fine their losses are gained
we hired gina she's going to be
working on a movie with us it's going to
be our first in-house movie it's going
to be absolutely
terrific now disney's got what eight or
nine billion dollars to push their
content
to push their canceled culture we have
you
and if i had the choice between eight or
nine billion dollars or you
i'm not s i'm not saying i would answer
right away okay i'm not saying i
wouldn't take a
minute to think about it but i think i
would still stick with you i'd like to
think i would stick with you uh thank
you so much for your support
we need you to subscribe go to
dailywire.com subscribe you'll save 25
using promo code gina g i n a
dailywire.com
subscribe we'll be right back with a lot
more
cozy old joe letting his eyelids sort of
flutter falling asleep in the rocking
chair by the fire in the oval office
and then his administration pushes
radical policies they're pushing them by
the way through
executive orders because these policies
are so radical they actually
aren't certain that they'd be able to
get them through their own
legislative majorities democrats control
the house they control the senate
and still the biden policies are so
radical they think i don't know maybe we
won't get your mansion maybe we won't
get
kirsten cinema jensaki our favorite
current white house press secretary
was asked about executive orders
curtailing second amendment rights
she couldn't rule it out what is your
timetable for action on
what the president calls common sense
measures and what's the realistic
hope that you have then they'll pass
both houses well
we haven't proposed a package at this
point so it's hard for me to make a
prediction about its
likelihood of passing but i will say
that the president is
somebody throughout his career who has
advocated for smart
uh gun smart gun safety measures um he
has
uh not afraid of standing up to the nra
he's done it multiple times and won
on background checks and a range of
issues and it is a priority to him on a
personal level but i don't have a
a prediction for you or a preview for
you on a timeline of a package
and certainly not what it would look
like and how it would go through
congress
so she can't tell you anything about a
gun control package
because they haven't worked out the
legislative side of this but this is
personally
important to joe biden joe biden has
already signed how many dozens of
executive orders since he entered office
he's obviously not afraid of taking
executive action
and she there she's unwilling to say
that uh that we won't get some some sort
of action
directly from the white house on the
second amendment
just as bad maybe even worse
gensake is not willing to state the
white house's position
on money going to the abortion industry
taxpayer money going to the abortion
industry
it is sadly the case in america that
the abortion industry is able to operate
it is legal
in in most circumstances to have an
abortion to kill babies in the womb
but we have something called the
amendment
the hyde amendment prevents taxpayer
money from going
to abortion services now it's kind of bs
because money is fungible so if if
government money goes to planned
parenthood which it does
trump cut that amount of money that goes
to planned parenthood but joe biden
kicked it back up again if you give the
money to planned parenthood and they say
okay don't worry
we're only going to put this money
toward computers
and the coffee machines right well okay
that means that just frees up other
money
to go to abortion when you deposit money
into a bank account you don't say okay
and this money is only going to go to
this thing and this money is good no
it's just a number on a screen
and you have the assets that you have
and you're going to spend them but
hypocrisy is the tribute vice pays to
virtue we have acknowledged in this
country even democrats
that we should not force taxpayers to
help subsidize the democrats satanic
schemes
to butcher little babies in the womb
hate that i have to be so blunt about it
but this is this is how
many americans myself included view what
they are doing they are asking us
to take our money and put it not just
towards something we don't like
not just toward a policy that we
disagree with because in a
republic we're always going to have to
have some taxpayer money going to things
that we disagree with
but to a unique case
a uniquely evil policy the butchering of
little
innocent babies in the womb
a violation of the right to life and a
pure
perfect violation of the right to life
that is not just one issue among many
but the prerequisite for all the other
rights
so jen saki please tell me moderate joe
is going to not force me to pay for
baby butchery with my tax dollars
can't do it can this administration
right now guarantee
if the american rescue plan is passed
that no taxpayer dollars will go to the
abortion industry which component of the
american rescue plan are you referring
to
i'll pull it up right here uh a 50
million dollar funding increase for the
title 10 program
uh 750 million dollars for global health
activities and billions in funding for
community health centers without
applying the height amendment
well the president's uh view on the hyde
amendment is well known as you have
stated in your question he also believes
that community health centers are a
key part of addressing the pandemic of
ensuring that people in communities
have access to vaccines have access to
treatment and information about about
making sure they're healthy and their
loved ones are healthy so that remains a
priority to the president
he's shared his view on the hyde
amendment i don't think i have anything
new for you
she's got nothing for you so
what's so shocking here is not that joe
biden would change his position
according to political wins that's what
joe biden is he is an empty suit
not surprised on that at all not
surprised that democrats would push
these policies to spend more money
to kill babies they've been doing that
for decades and this is just a
continuation of that policy
but her answer here to a direct question
and a simple one which is
since the law says you can't spend
taxpayer money on abortion
can you guarantee to me that the white
house will follow the law and not put
money this taxpayer money toward
abortion
she says joe biden's view on the hyde
amendment is very clear
yeah i know he opposes the heidemann he
didn't used to but until you know as of
five minutes ago he opposes the height
amendment
that's fine but now what you're telling
me is the will
the desires of the sitting president
supersede
the law is that it
trump was a pretty law and order guy he
was actually
for all the media hysteria about it he
actually did follow the rules and he
actually did do the things he said he
would do
generally speaking and he was called a
tyrant a fascist and authoritarian
here the spokesman for president biden
is coming out and saying yeah the law
says one thing
but joe wants something else so we're
going to do what joe wants
or at least we're not going to guarantee
that we're going to follow the law who
cares about the law
i am joe biden is the state joe biden's
desires are the state
and a flagrant disregard for law so the
reporter
to his credit very good reporter he
follows up on this question
jen saki because she's not very good at
her job and because she's defending the
indefensible she's got nothing
follow-up can you guarantee americans
who don't want their tax dollars
pro-life americans who don't want their
tax dollars funding abortion
can the administration guarantee those
tax dollars well i i think owen as i've
just noted
three quarters of the public supports uh
the components of the package wants to
see the pandemic
get under control wants to see people
put back to work vaccines and arms so i
think that answers your question okay
we're gonna move on
so on one hand obviously this does not
answer his question right
he's saying can you guarantee that
they're gonna follow the law and not
give the taxpayer money to abortion
and she says look three quarters of
americans want there to be a package
you say okay that has absolutely nothing
to do with my question she goes i think
that answers the question
on this deeper level it does answer the
question
you know she wouldn't answer it directly
but in her
really inexpert evasion she is answering
the question
joe biden as of now the stance of the
white house
is that he will be a lawless president
he will not be bound by the law if he
disagrees with the law
even a law that is so
controversial i mean you know
i'm not saying the law itself is
controversial but the it there is
there is controversy that has surrounded
it i don't think it ought to be
controversial that you know
people shouldn't have to fund this sort
of butchery but
it's a it's a really hotly contested uh
or a deeply felt issue if joe disagrees
with the law
then this is going to be a lawless white
house so much for science right as we
mentioned earlier on in the show
left doesn't really care very much about
the science of
biology whether on we're talking about
human lives little babies or whether
we're talking
about biological sex but they do push
a a sort of pseudoscience that i guess
is sort of related to biology
they're pushing a very radical form of
race
science they're positing a science of
race
whereby certain groups ought to be
favored they ought to receive certain
advantages
and certain groups ought to be
disadvantaged because
their their very race is uh wicked
evil needs to be abolished
abolished the principal of east side
community school in new york
sent out a graphic to his uh community
detailing the eight types of whiteness
this the
scale shows white identities ranging
from good
white identities to bad white identities
but even that is a little bit of a
misnomer because the premise of the
scale
is that white people are bad being white
just
being a white guy which by the way
the principle is is defining the left is
defining
sometimes the left wants to say hey
there's no such thing as whiteness
come on whiteness is a social construct
well
whiteness is not particularly important
to my identity i don't think of myself
primarily as white
think of myself catholic you know
american new yorker
at least originally now tennessee and i
think of all these
conservative whatever
but the left seems to know what white
means the left
seems to be able to identify who white
people are and the left is calling for
the abolition
of white people and for social
disadvantage for them but he says
the the good white people are so-called
white abolitionists
and the bad white people are white
supremacists so the eight categories
start with the worst one that's a white
supremacist who's a white supremacist i
don't know i don't really see very many
of them but i'm told that
75 million americans are white
supremacists then there's a white
voyeurism what is white voyeurism
i know it sounds kind of kinky i don't
know i don't know what white voice is
then there's white privilege notice by
the way it's shifting
obviously whoever put this graphic
together is not not
the most literate person in the world
you go you have white supremacist
then you get an ism then you get a
privilege white privilege
then you get white benefit i guess
that's where you
you know it's like you get certain
advantages from being white
like having to listen to these idiots
tell you how evil you are then there's
white confessional
so you it's like i guess the early
stages of white guilt
then there's a white critical that's
where you sort of don't like yourself
because of your skin color then there's
white traitor
so i guess that's just what it sounds
like and then there's
white abolitionist abolitionist
you want to abolish white people
you know it's it's funny because when
the the racial identitarians on the on
the right
you know called whatever you want to
call them white supremacist white neo
this or that when they say
and they're you know sort of most
fevered uh
protestations they'll say the left is
anti-white they want to abolish white
people and you say okay i'm not i don't
know about that
but then these guys come out and they
say that very thing they say yeah we
want to abolish
white people
what what do they think is going to
happen here
there was a pew research survey i've
mentioned it on the show a few times
that measured racial consciousness
you know how important race is to one's
sense of identity
and it found out that race is very
important to the identity
of uh black people hispanic people and
asian people in america
you just measure you say do you think
race is important are very important to
you and it's something like greater than
50
of those groups said yes it is the
number for white people was 15
white people broadly speaking do not
have this racial consciousness
it's ironic because we are told by the
left that white people
are the only people who can be racist
what does racism mean
i guess racism is i think of racism it
is a hatred and animosity for people on
the basis of their race
which is which is wrong because racism
is an affront to human dignity
but the way the left defines racism it's
sort of like
it's completely divorced from reality
because racism is apparently only held
by people who have
statistically speaking the least racial
consciousness of anybody in the country
what do you think the endgame of this is
because what i what i would like what i
think would
lead to a nice flourishing society is if
people didn't think primarily about race
i mean to you know to some degree you
think about race
i'm i'm descended from italian people i
eat a lot of pasta
obviously i speak with my hands i'm
doing that right now so i'm not saying
there's no such thing as race or
something like that
but race has its proper place
right i don't i don't lead marches i'm
not a spaghetti supremacist or something
like that
when you when you make an idol out of
the out of race you get racism very bad
the state has a proper place in our
lives when you make an idol out of the
state you get statism
uh individuality or this our sense is
individuals
has its proper place in a polity when
you make an idol out of that you got
hyper individualism society starts to
break down so you don't you don't want
to
make an idol out of these things you
want to utterly deny them either
but what the left is telling us is that
race is
basically the most important thing we
should make an idol out of it we should
pursue a racist
policy and we're going to castigate
people who have basically very little
racial identity on the basis of their
race
all that can do the only thing that will
happen from that is to increase racial
identity
and division maybe that's what the left
wants i assume it is
but this isn't just happening at some
kooky school in new york
but you know this you've seen this kind
of stuff in corporate boardrooms you've
seen this kind of stuff in a lot of psas
we do the woke commercials on my youtube
channel where you don't even know what
product these companies are selling
they're just selling
racial grievance or sexual grievance but
you see this
all around the country notably at a
school in philadelphia
that is honoring black communism
this there is a school in philadelphia
that uh is honoring black communism
and black power this comes to us by way
of christopher ruffo
at city journal who's covering critical
race theory so
this a teacher at a school william d
kelly school in pennsylvania
is leading 10 and 11 year old students
into the school auditorium to simulate a
black
power rally to free angela davis
a communist terrorist from prison
because she was once held in prison
awaiting a trial on charges of
conspiracy
kidnapping and murder and and they the
teacher in
in philly had the students walk around
with signs that read black power
jail trump a little anachronistic given
when angela davis was on trial
free angela and black power matters
they chanted the uh about africa they
chanted about ancestral power
then free angela free angela
angela davis now when i say she's a
communist i mean she was an actual
member of the communist party
and won the international lenin peace
prize
ironically named just given out by the
soviet union i mean
this woman is a hard core communist
terrorist this is the curriculum being
taught at william d kelly school now
you're going to be shocked to hear this
hold a sit down to hear this william d
kelly school
one of the worst performing schools in
pennsylvania i know i know you would
have thought with a with such a
brilliant curriculum such as this
that these would be the most urbane
educated
graduates anywhere in pennsylvania right
no william d kelly school has just three
percent proficiency in math by sixth
grade
nine percent proficient in reading by
graduation only 13
of students who graduate from the school
will have achieved basic literacy
now obviously this school should be shut
down
not serving students at all probably
destroying these students lives by
utterly failing them on education
filling their heads with a bunch of
stupid and evil ideas
are conservatives willing to say that
because this is a
radical agenda that is
being pushed probably the school doesn't
want to educate the children
because educated students would
understand what bunk all of this is
much better for for these political
radicals to keep everybody stupid and
uneducated
much more likely that people will be
compliant that way
but i think a lot of conservatives don't
want to touch this stuff because
conservatives don't want to be called
racist
now i know what you're thinking you're
thinking wait a second these people on
the right
or on the left rather they're the ones
pushing
racism the people on the right are
opposing racism i know
but but because of that conservatives
are so touchy about this sort of thing
they don't want to be accused of any
mean term especially because of the
extraordinary prominence of of racism
you know
in canceling people right this term
racism that they just don't want to
touch it
the only way that we're going to be able
to retake the culture
is by speaking plainly about these
things
people should not be given special
privileges because of their race
based on claims of historical grievance
or this sort of wicked ideology
communism whatever you know students
should not be participating in
three angela davis reenactments
students should not be taught that
communism is a good thing
you might be able to hear my newborn son
crying in the background right now
as i as i record from home and
he obviously is in great agreement that
society is in turmoil
and we have to do something about it we
need to be able to clearly state we
believe this we don't believe this
not just hey we're going to be inclusive
and yeah we can teach critical race
theory but we should also maybe teach
shakespeare or something no we need to
be much more
serious about this we need to be
exclusive about this we need to say
this trash does not belong in schools
teachers who teach this sort of thing
critical race theory this teacher
whoever did the angela davis thing that
teacher needs to be fired that teacher
probably should never be hired again by
any school that teacher
should be ostracized from his community
this sort of thing should if this does
show up at a school
the administrators of that school should
probably be fired they should at least
be deeply ashamed
we should we should say enough is enough
we're going to teach good things
that will form students brains in the
right way
that will teach them how to read and
write how to think
that will teach them to have a an
ordered view of the good
that will teach them virtue that will
teach them not to do vice not to engage
in vice
and to to shun all those sorts of wicked
things
the currently open sort of
subjectivist relativistic kind of
tone that we have on the right it ain't
going to work new york post is reporting
more schools are ditching shakespeare
remember i was
talking about this years ago when yale
started minimizing the role of
shakespeare in the english department
people said oh it's not a big deal come
on michael they're making the curriculum
a little more inclusive no they're not
they're not what the left is doing
is taking out the old good books and
replacing them
with new bad books and they're
justifying this on their stupid racial
theories
which are not only dumb but also
wrong and evil ayanna thompson who's an
english professor at arizona state
university
said in an interview that shakespeare
was a tool used to civilize black and
brown people
in england's empire and therefore we got
to get rid of it
she's half right the thing is
shakespeare is a tool
to civilize all of us
and as i don't know if i'm brown or i'm
swarthy i'm sicilian
are we brown i don't know are we white i
don't know maybe a sort of uh
maybe i'll be able to to escape the
worst uh worst consequences of the new
racial regime the left is pushing
just i'm a little sworthy probably not
though i think they're actually going to
go after me especially
on the basis of my views shakespeare
civilizes all of us shakespeare teaches
us about
human nature teaches us about who we are
teaches us how to make sense of our
freedom how to make sense of our worst
impulses how to make sense
of the places that we live in what the
leftist pushing is a sort of scientific
view they're saying there's no such
thing as human nature
different peoples are different
different races are different and by the
way it's all subjective and it's all
just words words words as hamlet would
say the left would know that
if they uh were not so illiterate
practically illiterate and then
culturally illiterate too
what the right is pushing what
conservatives advocate is a much more
serious scientific
view meaning there is objective reality
there is such a thing as human nature we
all share that human nature and we need
to
come to understand that that is science
too
that is a much more serious scientific
perspective the recognition of human
nature
and a politics that acknowledges human
nature that's much more serious than uh
whatever the sort of random covid
reopening policies
or the dire threats of global warming i
think that
the the attacks on human nature that are
being done the attacks on our
educational system
a far greater threat or far greater
threat than global warming or anything
else
all right stay bundled up stay warm out
there amid all this global warming
see you next time
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show